mélenchon est assez enclin à inventer à
produire ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
des punchline on pourrait utiliser les
exemples de ces discours pour pour
illustrer presque un cours d'art
oratoire
c'est ce genre d hypocrisie que la jeune
génération doit passer au kärcher je ne
suis pas leurs copains je suis une
tortue électorale 1 j'avance doucement
mais j'avance et g puis je les lièvres
savament un musée de voir comment vous
posez la question madame pécresse de
savoir quel effet ça me fait d'avoir un
million d'actions dans une entreprise
que je vais nationalisée dans la
rhétorique il ya plusieurs parties
différentes qui la constituent y'en a
notamment deux qui sont importantes
c'est la disposition c'est à dire
l'organisation la structuration du
discours et l'élocution c'est à dire le
style dont procède en particulier le
trait d'esprit l'apic l'attaquent la
punchline il fait partie de ces orateurs
comme on en a eu dans l'histoire
politique française qui connaissent
vraiment les passes delà de la
rhétorique c'est à dire les différentes
modalités du discours la manière de
jouer avec les figures de style la
manière d'arriver éventuellement à
manipuler à arriver à ses fins en
développant son propos selon différents
registres de langue en usant d'image
tout son sa rhétorique va consister
notamment à affaires souvent des
métaphores c'est-à-dire a emmené son
public ailleurs c'est comme jaurès qui
disait
rallumer tous les soleils
c'est des métaphores qui veulent
transmettre de l'énergie voir quelque
chose d'humoristique écouter les
zemmouris ce temps ça existe d'accord
prenez pas votre tête de victimes va
supporter quoi fait pas hollywood békaa
tous les cinq minutes dès que je dis un
mot là vous êtes là à taper sur le dos
sur le compte d'autre part c'est
l'antithèse qui peut être isolé dans une
bonne phase et qui peut caractériser de
manière générale l'ensemble d'un
discours dont la france n'est pas à
l'extrême droite la france c'est la
sécurité sociale vous les enseignants
les chercheurs les travailleurs par ces
gens qui donnent des ordres la mine
superbe à l'antithèse elle permet de
vous prendre melançon à mon avis parce
que c'est à la fois une figure de style
qui peut être identifié de manière très
rapide et c'est également un mode de
pensée et une opposition entre des
visions du monde et c'est à mon avis à
quelqu'un on sait bien que la de la
rhétorique l'art de la parole n'est pas
que un art du logos du discours de la
raison ou du style c'est aussi un art
corporel le peuple français aura été
petit à petit remplacer par un autre top
c'est dramatique c'est dramaturgique et
puis un jeu de scène avec beaucoup de
mimiques geste une expressivité dans son
visage qui est mise au service de cette
connaissance de la rhétorique
dans deux mois
le smic il est à 1400 euros par mois si
vous voulez pas voter macron
qui vous voulez
seulement si vous voulez dans deux mois
pas dans dix ans pas quand la terreur a
changé pas dans deux mois
tous les prix de première nécessité
seront bloqués
si vous voulez
l'été prochain ce conte 59 ans et 360
jours
la retraite
il fait son dada fort sûr si vous voulez
si vous voulez dans deux mois dans deux
mois avec des variations sur dans deux
mois le moment où il fait une pause et
que lee fait on se croirait vraiment
dans un sketch dans un one man show
c'est pas d'union dont on a besoin
c'est de clarté et de bobby lisation
populaire vous ne pouvez pas mobilisés
si vous donnez l'impression vous êtes un
menteur qui va ensuite à ranger ses
carabistouilles dans un coin avec ses
copains des autres partis je ne fuis pas
leurs copains que cela soit d une bonne
fois pour toutes lorsqu'il parle de deux
copains de carabistouilles de menteur
mélenchon choisi vraiment des mots
familiers et on voit qu'ils terminent
cette séquence ce passage pas que cela
soit dit qui est vraiment une formule là
d'une éloquence plus traditionnels tune
un propos soutenus et qui tranche
vraiment avec eux avec ce qui vient de
ce qu'il vient de dire juste avant il
est non seulement
enclins à faire des pics ou a touché
violemment l'adversaire mais aussi je
pense que sa force réside dans la
manière dialectique l'articuler
précisément d'organiser ses pensées ses
discours en variant le un caractère
parfois très soutenu très éloquent très
traditionnelle et qui va faire alterner
avec des adresses plus direct il connaît
l'héritage de la révolution de ses
grands discours à l'assemblée nationale
des tribuns
à vous de faire avec votre bulletin de
vote le printemps du peuple prenait le
pouvoir
notez
le 10 avril
rendez ce pays
confisquée par les vifs et avec cette
marée la drapeau rouge on a je pense
qu'ils veulent jouer sur une référence
plus ou moins subliminale plus ou moins
suggéré qui nous ramène directement à
l'éloquence révolutionnaire ou au
discours de robespierre danton la
constituante qui nous qui nous plonge
dans cette époque de la révolution
française dont il se dit l'héritier je
pense que tout le monde reconnaît à
mélenchon d'être un grand orateur
mélenchon il alterne ses punchlines
effectivement il n'y a pas peur
d'attaquer forêts et de taper là où ça
fait mal et c'est peut-être une
caractéristique qui est de l'évolution
du discours et du débat politique assez
récente dans notre société
[Musique]